well governments globally are enacting
strict measures to contain the
coronavirus raising questions about
individual freedoms and privacy rights
during a pandemic Israel has given its
security agencies the power to track the
mobile data of people suspected of
having the virus the government will use
the information to force them into
quarantine and warn those who have come
into contact with them South Korea's
taken similar steps by using mobile
phone and satellite technology to track
potential carriers Ali funk is the
researcher for the watchdog Freedom
House she says strict measures must be
put in place to ensure people's privacy
isn't at risk once the pandemic is over
we know from a public health perspective
it can be beneficial to track infected
or potentially infected people but what
we're really concerned about is that
this location tracking this the
health-related information is going to
be used for other purposes particularly
by governments who are using
surveillance to track down activists or
human rights defenders or journalists or
even opposition figures so if this
information has to be collected which I
think in order to justify the collection
we have to ensure that it is
scientifically supported as a way to
protect public health we need to ensure
that the restrictions are as narrow as
possible so then when we get out of this
our privacy protections are still there
because what's happening is these
current restrictions could have a
lasting effect way long after we get the
outbreak under control it's gonna be a
big challenge and it's something that we
see posts you know terrorist attacks or
other type of crises and that's why it's
very important for tech companies on who
are making these tools for civil society
groups ordinary citizens to really
understand what type of limitations are
happening now so that once we get past
this really scary time we can fight
again to have our privacy rights back to
us and free expression and freedom of
association and assembly